there's a lot of mismatches you know
volkanovsky if he's checked in Focus
doesn't get caught with anything he
should be Yaya Rodriguez Robert wicker
duplici's awful matchup for duplicity's
Robert wicker should mop the floor with
him Turner Dan hooker's tough fight for
Dan hooker then Bo nickel and Gore to
get on my face po Nichols minus 1300
then Jalen Turner Dan hooker Jalen
Turner is a minus 250 and then Robert
Whittaker or duplicis is a minus 410
that's a massive massive favor if this
was NBA or NFL the author never mind
it's 410 but if it was you'd bet every
penny you have on the NFL team Ram reyno
pantosia minus 180 plus 55. focus is a
minus 410 in a championship fight that's
insane dude but you made a great night
of fights meaning you need some dope
Knockouts dope finishes if there's an
upset hell yeah it could be card of the
year